From doubtful executives to his own personal
demons, actor and filmmaker Jason Mewes has
beaten the odds to become a cult favorite
Hollywood icon, known to many, beloved by
all.
Here's how it all happened — and what might
happen next.
Jason Mewes was born in the small town of
Highlands, New Jersey, and grew up having
essentially no ambitions of ever becoming
an actor, director, or a stoner icon in the
vein of Cheech and Chong.
In Highlands, Mewes and his longtime collaborator
Kevin Smith lived only a couple of blocks
away from each other and attended the same
high school, but they weren't necessarily
friends right away.
For one, the younger Mewes was still a student
after Smith had already graduated.
For another, Smith and his circle of friends
frequently found him to be, in Mewes' words,
"obnoxious and weird."
But over time, Smith bonded with the oddball
freshman out of a shared love of comics and
pop culture, and an increasing appreciation
on Smith's part for Jay's oddball — and
sometimes profane — sense of humor.
Despite Mewes showing no real interest in
theater or performance as a teenager, Smith
would often remark to Mewes that someone should
put him in a movie.
It was only fitting that Smith, an aspiring
filmmaker himself, would be the one to do
it.
Jason Mewes got his first brush with fame
when Smith wrote a role for him in what would
become his debut feature, Clerks.
In his first appearance as the character,
Jay is barely a performance.
He's just…
Jay.
Being interviewed for a documentary commemorating
the tenth anniversary of Clerks, Smith recalled,
"I gave him the script and he read it and
I was like, 'What do you think?'
He's like, 'I don't know if I can do this.'
I'm like, 'Dude, it's you!'"
Though close to the character and naturally
charismatic, Mewes still had to confront stage
fright when it came time to shoot the movie.
In the beginning, he was so nervous in front
of the camera that he at times asked the crew
to leave during his performances, meaning
some scenes of Clerks were shot with literally
nobody behind the camera.
Mewes said in the Clerks making-of doc that
his youthful antics had always been about
entertaining himself, not others.
As soon as an audience was involved, he froze
up.
"Like as soon as I got an audience, I just
felt really silly doing it for other people,
and just being like, 'All right everyone,
get ready!
That anxiousness had unexpected benefits,
though.
Mewes' inability to sell a crucial line in
a climactic scene is what inspired Silent
Bob's one line of dialogue in the film, establishing
Bob in series canon as a mostly mute character
who only speaks when he has wisdom to drop.
"You know there's a million fine lookin women
in the world.
They don't all bring you lasagna at work.
Most of em just cheat on ya."
… "C'mon, limp d---."
The sale of Clerks to Miramax meant that Jason
Mewes' performance as Jay would be seen by
many more people than his circle of friends
in New Jersey.
Suddenly, this $27,000 indie film was on its
way to becoming a bona fide cult classic — and
Hollywood was noticing.
Smith's second film, Mallrats, was fast-tracked
into production with the backing of a major
studio.
Unlike Clerks, filmed with a skeleton crew
over nearly a month's worth of night shoots,
Mallrats was a real deal production with real
deal money behind it — and the people putting
up the money had opinions.
Specifically, they liked the character of
Jay, but they didn't really like the person
playing Jay.
This lead to an unenviable situation in which
Mewes had to audition for a chance to essentially
play himself.
In the suits' view, Smith was a wunderkind,
but Mewes was an amateur, and they misunderstood,
or underestimated, his appeal.
The studio tried to recast the role with a
more established comic actor like Breckin
Meyer or Seth Green.
While Smith won the right to cast Mewes in
Mallrats, there were strings attached: if
Mewes' performance wasn't satisfying on day
one, he'd be fired and replaced.
It was only when the executives got a look
at Mewes in action that they realized he was
simply irreplaceable.
"The whole f----- world's against us, dude,
I swear to god."
Despite the troubles he was put through by
the studio, Jason Mewes maintains that Mallrats
was his favorite one of Smith's films to work
on.
"Clerks was the first movie, but to me, really,
Mallrats is my first movie, because it was
like it became real."
While Mewes would go on to spend his adulthood
in show business, the real-life act of moviemaking
was still a novelty to him at the time of
Mallrats.
“I'm in Minnesota, staying in a hotel, and
there's wardrobe, and there's stunt guys,
and I get to hang from a grappling hook, and
I get to meet Stan Lee for the first time."
Mewes would later go on to cross paths with
the Marvel Comics magnate on multiple occasions
in the years to come, even casting him for
a cameo for his own movie, Madness in the
Method, in 2019.
"Boy, I heard he's a knucklehead."
Though Mallrats didn't exactly make bank at
the box office, Smith got another chance to
make a movie, this time mining more personal
territory for the less slapsticky, more artsy
Chasing Amy.
This story had less room for Jay and Silent
Bob, though the characters do appear in a
pivotal scene.
The movie also introduced comic book alter
egos for the characters: the marijuana-themed
superheroes Bluntman and Chronic.
It's the in-universe creators of those characters
that the story of Chasing Amy revolves around.
But despite his increasing notoriety, Mewes
continued working "regular guy" jobs until
well after you'd think he would have hung
it up to go Hollywood.
"I did Chasing Amy, and I went back to delivering
pizza and doing construction and stuff.
So I worked a regular job for years.
It really wasn't until after Dogma that I
stopped working construction and delivering
pizza."
Mewes reached the height of the zeitgeist
in 2001, when he starred in Jay and Silent
Bob Strike Back, the first film in Smith's
universe to revolve entirely around the duo.
But that professional success didn't necessarily
reflect a healthy personal life.
By then, Mewes had spent years going down
the path of drug addiction, specifically to
opiates.
Mewes was born to a mother with addiction
issues of her own, and spent his early adolescence
practicing a straight-edge lifestyle — an
identity which had thoroughly eroded by the
time he and Smith teamed up for Clerks.
But what started out as perfectly innocent,
even charming substance abuse had become a
bleak, life-or-death situation by the early
2000s.
An arrest for heroin possession in 1999 was
compounded by another arrest warrant, issued
in 2001, over a failure to make a court date
in New Jersey.
The circumstances led Smith to decline to
cast Mewes in his sixth film, Jersey Girl
— an unfortunate first for the frequent
collaborators, whose friendly relationship
was being strained to the breaking point by
Mewes' addiction.
The warrant ultimately led Jason Mewes to
return to New Jersey and face the music, dealing
with the legal problem, and perhaps his addictions
as well.
“I got fed up.
I was like, I have to take care of this warrant,
because even if I get sober and I'm doing
good in California, this warrant will hang
over my head forever.
So I went there and took care of it."
Mewes was sentenced to four to six months
of rehab in New Jersey, with a period of probation
to follow.
His surrender to authorities started a process
of recovery that continues to this day.
He credits the success to his support system,
staying busy with work and surrounding himself
with friends who aren't shy about keeping
him accountable.
"Keeping busy is a big thing.
[...] I realized for me, the people who really
care, it's, 'Hey, why do you have that beer
in your hand.
And I'm like, 'Oh, I'm just passing it to
so-and-so.'
But a friend who's like, 'Hey, you've been
sober two years and you're really addicted
to drugs, not booze.
You can have a beer.
You can have one beer.'
That to me isn't… he might be a friend,
but not really.
So that to me was a big deal.
Surrounding myself with people who knew, no,
I can't have a beer, because then I'll be
smoking crack in a month, and I'll disappear."
In the years since he committed to sobriety,
Jason Mewes has continued to work as an actor,
being cast in many smaller movies that you
may not have heard of.
In 2010, Mewes was also a cast member on Todd
and the Book of Pure Evil, a Canadian comedy
series that was canceled after two seasons.
Much like Mewes' early movies, the show is
something of a cult favorite with a small
but dedicated fanbase.
“I think when people see it they love it,
it's just them finding it.
But yes, Todd and the Book of Pure Evil.
Definitely I believe you guys will be able
to find it somewhere."
Another lesser-known film Mewes is proud of
is Zombie Hamlet, which is more or less exactly
what it sounds like.
"I'm shocked more people didn't see that,
because it was a really funny movie."
Out of the dozens of projects Jason Mewes
has been involved with over the years, one
he's most proud of is his directorial debut,
2019's Madness in the Method.
The movie was born out of two desires: breaking
out of the stoner niche as an actor, and stepping
behind the camera for a substantial feature
project.
Prior to Madness, Mewes had only directed
a few music videos and shorts, experiences
he enjoyed.
But they left him wanting more.
Soon enough, he was on independent film sets
with his mind wandering toward bigger, more
involved aspects of the production.
The film is a kind of meta-narrative that
takes place in a slightly heightened version
of the real world, following Mewes as he attempts
to learn method acting with the help of a
near-mythical guidebook.
Owing partly to the character's addictive
personality, things get out of hand quickly.
"I read the book [...] I'm told to read it
slow and really soak it in, and I read it
too fast.
And then from there, an accident happens,
and then a killing spree happens.
And it's a comedy drama."
On top of his directorial debut being released,
2019 also proved big for Jason Mewes in another,
more familiar way, with the filmmaker stepping
back into the Jay role.
The part has been revived as a part of Smith's
13th movie, Jay and Silent Bob Reboot, a sequel
to Strike Back that Smith has called, quote,
"literally the same f—ing movie all over
again."
Well, if you liked it the first time…
“Alright guys, welcome to behind the scenes
of the set of Mallrats 2.”
In typical ironic fashion, the movie is effectively
a reboot that lampoons reboots, following
Jay and Silent Bob as they head back to Hollywood,
again, seeking sweet revenge for the industry's
slights against them — again.
This time, they're out to stop a blockbuster
reimagining of Bluntman and Chronic, now starring
former Batman Val Kilmer and current Supergirl
Melissa Benoist.
And while Jay went sober as his namesake for
Clerks II, the sequel seems to have the fictional
character back in the mood of rolling fatties
and smoking blunts.
Outside of filmmaking, Mewes has also found
a second unexpected niche as a podcaster and
a stage performer, touring with the stand-up
show "Jay Mewes and His A-Mewes-ing Stories."
He's also begun streaming content on Twitch
under the name JayMewes.
"Yeah man, it's been fun.
It's like between this movie and reboot, and
streaming, and the stand up comedy, it's been
good."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.